hello everyone in this video I am going
to share with you what is probably the
best advice that I ever received from
any one of my seniors
now I have already shared this story
with many of my students here at kgp IIT
kharagpur
so I thought that since they were
benefited my students here I'll also
share the story with those outside KGB
this advice was immensely beneficial to
me it was immediately useful to me so
what is this story to tell you the story
let me take you back to the year 2005.
I've just finished my first year back
then I was I just stepped into second
year in the department of mechanical
engineering this is my third semester
Autumn semester going on probably it was
sometime in July or August and to give
you the proper context this was an
immensely loaded semester loaded means
extremely pressure full semester so we
had subjects at the same time
simultaneously going on like fluid
mechanics Dynamics partial differential
equations transform calculus mechanics
of materials
economics Workshop which was like a
hardcore lab and on top of everything we
also had extra academic activity the
official extra academic activity which
was NCC for me
so we had all this uh load going on
officially and on top of that this was
the the third semester we had just come
to the senior halls and the expectation
was that we would be participating in
various kinds of activities uh like
extracurricular activities
uh various Sports various cultural
activities so it was immensely loaded
now
because I was kind of academically
serious I always had this notion of
maintaining my grade point average and I
was very worried like what is going to
happen so during one of the interactions
with the seniors I I mentioned this that
how am I ever going to cope up so this
was of course a question in the minds of
many of my friends also who were at
least academically serious and those who
are not academically serious so how are
you going to cope up so ah so it is this
is this is the context in which I I Came
Upon This advice so uh this senior uh he
was so I was in second year he was in
third year uh his name uh is nirmalia
sengupta okay so I just uh so just
starting this video five minutes before
this uh I looked up uh nehemalia where
he is now uh it turns out that he is one
of the co-founders of a company called
interested dot one so they are uh they
are looking into innovative ways of
training uh children uh children
including teenagers also
so some kind of after school activities
and various Innovative things so that's
interesting so it's actually
particularly interesting because uh he's
doing this now and I got some kind of
advice some kind of academic advice from
him back then
now what was the advice
so really understand the importance of
this you have to uh you have to
understand that we have uh in our campus
a lot of extracurricular activities and
there's something called the technology
students gym Khanna which is like the
like the governing body for everything
related to Student Activities and there
is a lot of official posts which the
students hold these are extremely busy
posts like all throughout the year the
students have to do a lot of work those
who hold this post and uh nirmalia
sengupta he was one of the general
secretaries holding the post of the
General Secretary of social cultural
activities uh
and this was extremely loaded okay so
this is the overall context and uh what
he told me is as follows he said look
jivan
I am the G6 General Secretary of social
cultural activities
I don't have any time
okay uh forget so you so he is telling
me that you are worried about not being
able to spend enough time on your
studies look at me so he's telling to me
look at me I don't have time to stay in
my room forget staying in my room and
even relaxing forget studying I don't
even get time to sleep some days so
there have been ABS actually stretches
of time when he did not go without
sleeping for two days at a time so that
was the kind of business that they had
back then and he was also enormously
responsible for the conduction of the
Spring Fest the the annual cultural
Festival which is actually held in the
spring semester but they have to do the
bulk of the work during the Autumn
semester so he was extremely busy so he
tells me that look I am I'm so busy I
don't have time to study like I don't
even have time to sleep so when do I
study and please understand that I know
this that although he is not an academic
Superstar but he he managed to maintain
his grade point average to it to a
respectable extent okay so more than
respectable extent I would say
he told me so how do I manage this okay
so what is this piece of advice so he
told me that since I don't have any time
to study
but when I go to class okay this is the
piece of advice when I go to class I
forget everything I forget that I am the
general secretary social cultural I have
these enormous responsibilities I forget
everything I sweep my mind clean and I
just focus in my class and all the
studying that I do in entirely through
the semester takes place as the teacher
is teaching me in class during the
lectures there is no extra studying he
doesn't get time to come home and maybe
he does the assignments just to keep up
but like self-studying and concentrating
in books none of that happens so
whatever he studies whatever knowledge
he imbibes it is strictly strictly
directly during the lectures as the
professor is speaking so that that
requires a certain level of focus and
single-minded devotion so he told me so
that this is the key okay you do not
have to spend an enormous amount of time
uh coming back to your room and studying
uh all throughout the semester if you
can do that that's great okay if you
have that luxury of time I don't have
that so whatever I study it is takes
place during the class okay
so he maintains this like like he he
used to maintain this regimen okay no
matter whether he has uh he has he has
taken an all-nighter okay he has put in
an all-nighter all-nighter means he has
not slept all throughout the night even
though he even then he would go to class
uh doesn't matter what other activities
is going on
he would not be unduly concerned with
them during the lectures okay of course
he would be concerned I know that but
still he'd he'd make it to class but
once in class you just focus
so
I thought that if he can focus like that
let me also try
okay let me also try this and I did try
okay I did not have his kind of like
single-minded focus in class uh to be
able to manage just through that because
I had to come back and study and and and
let's be honest it is possible to
maintain a respectables grade point
average by that it is not possible to
get an excellent grade point average
using that okay but
in order to get to the excellent grade
point average you actually have to focus
in class okay that is the first
requirement and I'm saying this because
there are many first-year students and
second year students who maybe as a
residue of their study habits from from
the pre uh engineering days uh they
always have this thing that okay
whatever that the teacher is teaching in
class I'll just go back to my room and
study from the books and like whatever
the study materials is
the effect is not really the same okay
so particularly in our kind of semester
system and I have said this multiple
times in my various videos it is not
always the same because here at least in
the iits the nits the good engineering
colleges
what happens is that the teacher or the
professor who is teaching he only says
the question paper it's a very compact
uh very loaded semester so within that
very limited time within the within the
extreme constraints of it you have to
make the best use of it and the first
step towards that the absolute first
step is the Crux of the idea is that you
have to absolutely focus in class okay
there are there may be maybe many of you
in the first and second year who are
slowly getting interested in extra
academic activities but no matter what
you do once you come to class forget
everything okay and make the best use of
class make like extract 100 out of your
class
so that's it and uh nirmalia
if you are watching this video uh thank
you so much I never got around to uh
thanking you because when I was young I
did not realize although I followed your
advice I never realized the the True
Value the genuine value uh and the the
preciousness of your advice so now that
I am mature enough I'm thanking you if
you ever watch this video and I hope you
don't mind that I took your name uh in
giving this very useful suggestion to
the to the current students all right
thank you everyone very much and all the
best